the right to be forgotten the transfer
of your personal data across borders or
the age at which you can sign up to
facebook or crucial questions in the
21st century with many of us really
surrendering sensitive personal
information MEP is want to ensure the
highest standards of data protection I
think with this new regulation the
European Union sets a standard which I
would say could be also a global
standard as we are the biggest market in
the word and which creates a trustful
environment for consumers online and I
think in the future privacy made in
Europe will be also a trademark private
companies are not the only ones that
want to know who we are and what we do
national governments are also interested
in using data in the fight against crime
and terrorism if police is in directions
using the personal data then there are
quite strict and clear and transparent
rules and these rules from one side they
should be not not in contradiction with
the effectiveness of police with updated
regulations on all these issues the
right of Europeans are now more attuned
to the habits